all right today is national book lovers
day and our rocky theist is exploring a
local spot where all the bookworms and
word nerds can celebrate
welcome to the writer's block a
brilliant play on words i might add drew
co-owner
of this beautiful spot here in downtown
so let's cheers to national book lovers
day because what is a book shop without
coffee
you got to have the right buy you got to
set the vibe okay and i imagine that
this cage here in your
shop is a nod to i know why the cage
bird sings or
it's like it's kind of an all-purpose
nod we are an artificial bird sanctuary
so that's part of it and it's also a bit
of a throwback to
old casino cages i love that we love a
vegas not okay so let's walk through
this beautiful shop
tell us about the lit scene here in
vegas yeah so that that the literary
scene here has
expanded exponentially since we opened
seven years ago
we have our independent bookstore and
coffee shop here
our building is also home to a variety
of writers and residents
that's cool and that makes sense to me
because this place feels like home
thank you it's so comforting yeah it's
it's really cool that that that we've
got that atmosphere with real writing
going on and
we also um we also offer creative
writing workshops
oh that's amazing and those are starting
again this saturday okay and is this is
this for adults and children
how does that work good question these
are just for children um they're ages 5
through 18
at the workshops um they are entirely
free
and after a long hiatus we are bringing
them back on
saturday oh congratulations and i know
because that is your pride and joy here
what do the kids actually learn they
actually they will write
creative stories usually fiction and
then they leave with a book at the end
of the workshop
you're the children that come take your
writing courses write an actual book
they do
you get them printed exactly so we it is
all project based and results in a real
book
a kid wrote this that is amazing that's
so cool okay so
for kids at home or parents at home
watching and they want to get their
creative juices flowing what's an
exercise they can do at home
so they could try a game of like
exquisite corpse where each person uh
gives a line of the story and then the
next
tries to complete it oh that's fun okay
give me a line give me a like okay
it was dark and stormy
and i had to report outside
the sky very it was daunting that's good
did we do good okay
you guys finished the story at home i'll
send it back to you happy national book
lovers day
cheers again